sur l'Ukraine
amx-10rc je ne communique pas le nombre
publiquement parce que les chiffres qui
ont circulé d'ailleurs aussi où là sont
des chiffres qui sont qui sont faux je
tiens à dire que là où mais vous en
venez du théâtre craignant là où nous
notre partenaire ukrainien nous attend
de manière très pressante et je les
comprends c'est sur deux segments
l'artillerie sur lequel on a fait nos
preuves alors TF1 compris d'ailleurs
même si c'est l'ancienne génération
César César matériel nouveau César
entretien du matériel déjà donné César
pièces détachées César au but César
carburant toute la galaxie et ses
informations pardonnez-moi toute la
galaxie du sujet artillerie qui est
absolument clé sur lequel avec le
président de la République on a le fait
le choix évidemment de de non pas de se
mettre mais assez naturellement les
performances françaises étant ce
qu'elles sont voilà je rajouterai les
léru puisque là aussi ce sont quand même
des armes redoutablement efficace qui
ont été donnés au mois de décembre
dernier et qui par définition aussi
trouve toute sa place sur sur le théâtre
la deuxième des choses c'est la défense
solaire vous m'avez interrogé sur le
sujet alors crotale l'enjeu c'est pas
tant le nombre de systèmes que le nombre
de missiles pour armer les dispositifs
retard on a des discussions avec ce
nombre de partenaires qui ont des
missiles pour pouvoir les donner à
l'Ukraine j'en dis pas plus parce que
tout ça n'est pas complètement abouti
les Ukrainiens sont véritablement
satisfaits du matériel qui a été donné
pratiquement tous les tirs de crotale
sont des tirs d'interception réussie
donc ça évidemment c'est c'est quand
même quelque chose d'important sont des
vies d'ailleurs qui sont sauvés il faut
le dire la défenseur vous le savez mieux
quiconque c'est pas que pour protéger
les intérêts civils ça permet aussi de
protéger le théâtre du champ de bataille
donc ça a aussi des vertus importantes
on le voit bien d'ailleurs sur le
comportement de l'aviation russe me
semble-t-il où on voit quand même la
défense solaire ukrainienne se durcir
petit à petit avec des effets induits
sur le comportement russe qui se qui se
constate et l'urgence pour moi pour nous
italiens Guido crevetot mon homologue et
moi-même c'est de mettre suffisamment la
pression sur MBDA et sur Thalès pour que
le dispositif somme t que l'équivalent
un peu des patriotes américains sont
livrés le plus vite possible parce que
la masse pour le coup la couverture et
l'efficacité de ce dispositif est clé
j'ai rajouté GM 200 qui a été acheté par
le fond de soutien à Thalès donc là pour
le coup c'est les deux segments sur
lequel il faut avancer vite le troisième
segment sur lequel évidemment il y a des
conversations sur les avions des
discussions qui sont en cours présents
un public a dit il y a pas de tabou la
difficulté elle est évidemment
logistique et en matière de formation
elle est enfin l'avion c'est aussi ce
qui va avec au sol c'est évidemment la
capacité d'entretien mécanique tout ça
dans des horizons de temps qui sont par
définition absolument pas du court terme
on sait tous mais je ne m'engage pas oui
des discussions ont lieu avec les
Ukrainiens il y a pas de tabou sur ce
sujet comme il y a pas de tabou sur la
question de la formation non le
quatrième point sur lequel on a une
pression c'est sur les obus c'est sur
les munitions ça je crois que là pour le
coup c'est l'actualité pour l'ensemble
de l'Occident BTD américaine compris
l'accès à la poudre c'est pour ça aussi
que j'ai pris un symptôme de décision
sur lequel je ne reviens pas mais la
capacité d'endurance de l'armée
ukrainienne qui fait face avec courage
elle est aussi dans cette capacité à
tenir sur le volet des munitions et de
l'entretien du matériel on vient aussi
aux questions qui ont été abordées
précédemment